hey what's going on it's bill burr i'm
out here on the road
and uh this week's monday morning
podcast i actually recorded a few weeks
ago
with uh the great jim gaffigan
and uh we were only supposed to do a
half hour it was supposed to be a
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast
um and i don't know what happened we
started talking
we talked comedy we talked life and then
somewhere about a half about halfway
through it we just started [ __ ] on
each other
and had a great time just trashing each
other and somehow it ended up being like
an hour and a half long so guess what
it's now a [ __ ] two-parter
sorry i did five shows and i'm getting
over a cold no i don't have covid
and yes i think the world is round all
right
or is this the [ __ ] robot deep state
version of me you don't know do you
um so anyway uh this is going to be the
first half's going to be on monday this
is the monday morning podcast that
you're about ready to watch and then we
got the uh
the thursday afternoon
which will be the second half or maybe
it's just audio i don't know we did it
at atc i have no [ __ ] idea what's
happening but he told me to record a
video so it must be video all right
that's it oh for all you colt fans
congratulations
all right you had a hell of a first half
you know we gave you a [ __ ] field
goal
and uh but you know mac jones he threw
two does the guy implode no he comes
right back and he scares the [ __ ] out of
you
all of a sudden it's 20 to 17 you're
like oh my god
do we need to go weigh their cleats is
this why they're coming back
so
i i love that we got humbled
and i think uh you know that's i'd
rather lose in december than in january
because we all know what losing in
january is like don't you indianapolis
especially to the chargers at home sorry
all right that's it everybody go [ __ ]
yourselves uh merry christmas
happy kwanzaa
and also
hanukkah
and flat earth
hey what's going on everybody uh
it's bill burn it's time for the monday
morning podcast and uh every once in a
while
i have a special guest on here and uh
this is one of these days this is a
gentleman
from the midwest from a red state yes
then i'm going to reach across my blue
state be in massachusetts you are uh
kentucky
indiana you know what's so funny
this is the whitest podcast this is ever
this is like i mean we might we should
be shooting this in charlottesville this
is like
this is like a meeting the three
percenters would have the exact same
podcast as there's nothing i actually
think uh
white supremacists would maybe leave
their group if they watched like yeah
they'd be like not that white yeah not
that white they're like we we you know
yeah every once in a while we like to
listen to jackson five some of the
before we kill somebody i mean by the
way this lighting i i i'm not a vain man
but this lighting's pretty i don't i'm
not even this white yeah
we decided we were gonna enhance it with
some overhead nice track lighting yeah
for the pigmentless
what is what is your nationality
background how
far into northern europe are you i i
it's the north pole no
i'm i'm all irish
what are you and uh yeah 99 point
whatever irish in english i never did
the 23 in meek just in case you're
related to aaron burr
i'm not i mean i have the same last name
but i'm not unfortunately you have you
done it no but i'm worried that there's
a serial killer in my family and i just
don't want a deal there i had a
i had a relative that was
on trial for murder
oh yeah i mean yeah you go far enough
back yeah you're gonna find one either
someone went on trial or they did
something
so what so wait a minute so this
navigation you don't i've never so like
i'm german irish you're german irish
yeah so like
yeah that's what you know like when you
introduce me you know indiana red state
i'm like
when i started touring i was shocked at
how when i would go around and do boston
radio how they all
were like on
they were big w fans and i'm like isn't
massachusetts supposed to be lyra like
massachusetts is the weirdest liberals
they're liberal in that i think that
they
you know union [ __ ] state job yeah
blah blah blah but everyone listen i
mean i'm going back 27 years so i can't
talk about massachusetts now because i
don't know what it's like now but when i
was there it had this weird thing where
it was i can't even say super racist it
was as racist as anywhere else is what
i'm finding when i'm out there um we
just had like uh the bussing thing so
that it just
glommed on to us
right and they act like you know upstate
new york is just welcoming everybody
with open arms but the second you get
into western massachusetts all these
evil white people and i just having done
the road and talking to people
afterwards
yeah i just reminded me of a gig i did a
long time ago the first time i went into
new york this guy
i was head uh opening for wanted to go
water skiing and it was right after
labor day and everybody had put their
boats away so he knew that there was
going to be wives there so if he made
them laugh he could talk him in so he
was on
just said man i love water skiing just
kidding he was killing he just kept
saying he loved water skiing so sure
enough some wife took the bait and this
guy took his boat out for us dragged us
across the lake and he had a you know he
had a great time we had a great time we
go back to his place finger sandwiches
and everything and he decides to tell a
couple of jokes and it was just like wow
whoa yeah where are we and she's going
oh come on stop it it was just like you
know uh two guys walking to a bar n-word
and it was just something yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i mean two of those and then
we kind of like we're like
all right man
is like being from the midwest like when
i got to new york city everyone was like
oh is your you know like i tell you to
joke around it's like like if i would go
back to indiana he was like how's
everyone at the clan meeting you know
like assuming that it was all but like
it's everywhere yes it's really you know
it's not like uh
this is the white guilt of your own
state
podcast yeah no but we're not defending
away it's everywhere man you know
everybody's doing it but it is you know
there's a great documentary called uh
civil war that i
woke up at like 4 a.m because i had like
three kids my kids in my bed what if i
had three kids in my bed yeah
i had three kids i had met him earlier
no um and so jesus juice
and they uh
but like it talks about how
you know the north was all about
freeing the slaves and then the slaves
were freed and there was the great
migration and the north was like wait a
minute right dude i mean it changed the
whole
i think they were always like that and
they just acted like my ex i actually
have a theory that the reason why the
people in the south whatever they're
doing the tomahawk chop yeah and have no
empathy is because northern whites have
not shown them empathy
since before the civil war always were
acting like they were dumber and all of
this type of stuff and to this day like
talk show hosts can do monologue jokes
about them [ __ ] their own sister and
everybody's just sitting there laughing
so they've always been treated as less
than so i i feel like uh you know
there's a big phony thing with northern
whites acting like oh we're we're the
good white people oh yeah yeah
definitely that was i mean i know you're
a piece of [ __ ] just like make you i'm
very flawed i'm very fluent
i'm very well you know but you have that
easy speaking like i'm very flawed no
well i think it's weird you know i've
had people like
friends peers be like well like they'll
curse in front of me and they'll be like
sorry to curse them for like i'm
like i'm some evangelical like we're in
a
in a bible study class and that's why
do you work clean i work relatively
clean but it's not as if
you know
me or brian regan don't curse in
everyday life it's just different styles
of comedy right so i don't know just
bringing that up that's all right so
bill i curse my brains out you do
because i don't i don't know how to
write a joke so i have to scream my way
through my act that's not true at all
but
no women so i can show you some tape
let's talk about
let's talk about um
doing specials and
when you're silicas we've discussed this
before off
the air you do it in two years
two years i do one of y'all kind of like
when i feel like uh
i'm ready to do one yeah and um i think
that that works out the best because if
i was to look at like i remember when
like when louis was putting him out
every single year if i ever got caught
up
in that mindset that i have to be able
to put him out as fast as he does
uh like that i just knew that wouldn't
work for me so i couldn't get like uh
you know when you're a young comic you
just said what what is this person doing
what are they doing i need to be doing
what all of these people that are
successful are doing
fortunately when he started doing that i
was further enough in my career to be
like you can see your perspective yeah
like i can't i can't make an act work in
a year i mean that that i can't do that
i mean that's also like even when he was
doing that uh he was also
doing an entire television show it was
unbelievable and writing and editing it
like people don't realize it's like if
you're touring
doing stand-up
uh even you know like you act too it's
like if you do some acting projects
that'll take you out of the mix for a
month or two yeah but like if you're
doing a show
and you're
you know it's just an insane problem so
like that's
like what louie was doing was kind of
otherworldly but like yeah i do feel
like that's why i'm saying so if i was
to look i was just looking at the
stand-up aspect to forget about yeah
writing a whole season and doing all and
making all those story arcs and
everything work and dealing with net
network notes and deadlines and then
doing the press just for the friggin
show and the fact that he was still
knocking out these hours
yeah i'm glad i also didn't add that
because then i'd be like wow man i knew
i sucked but jesus right right
but i also think it's one of those
things where um
whatever
like the norm
keeps shifting like the norm was like
you know
leery did that one special
and it was like boom and it was there
was an expectation he never had to do
another one i think he did do another
one but locked and loaded
but that one came out like four or five
years later and that was fine and it was
it wasn't hey man where's your neck
because people do that where's your next
one yeah when's your next so it's
it shifts and it's it's
it's shifting and also
the streaming platform stuff changes
constantly
you know so and you've only done netflix
yes you stay where daddy tells you to
stay oh
no i see
i know where this is going i know where
this is going i've had a great run in
netflix no netflix look i'm back at
netflix oh you are back yeah i thought
you were still over there with your side
check amazon no no
look netflix is this is going to be a
netflix smashing no no no i mean not at
all why don't you come over to amazon no
no no no no wait for that
no it is uh
that's not it at all it's it is
interesting to see the different
platforms but nobody can compete with
netflix nobody
it's like but that being said you know
three years five years things can change
yeah i mean i mean
people used to laugh at netflix i
remember when i first might i always
tell the story when my first special got
on netflix
i had people say you can you might might
have seen it special on netflix and
people would snicker
really because they were considered the
the blockbuster that delivers right and
and people hadn't caught on to what they
were doing yet but every single like who
would have thought when we started out
in this business that nbc cbs and abc
would be clamoring for eyeballs so
everybody everybody has their run
everybody has their run and you you just
kind of you get in with
whoever you fit in with
and uh you save your money you stay away
from the crack you know the crack you're
trying to stay away from the crack you
get eight hours of sleep
try and get eight yeah are you a mapper
uh you know what i i
gave into naps in my early 30s and then
i got away from them for the last 20
years i don't know why i remember when i
was still living with bobby kelly yeah
we'd be we had a railroad apartment and
i would literally walk to the middle
room between the roommates name who was
on the lease and bobby slept in the
living room and i would just go all
right dude i'm going to lay down for a
minute and he would do it too and he
would be out there and then we'd wake up
just like a half hour later yeah he was
like dude you always call the naps bro
you know you're calling the naps and it
was just like
and we go down to the cellar and we like
have that extra energy so i'm trying to
get back
into that because i got back into
therapy my therapist was talking to me
she goes you look tired
i was just like yeah well you got to
peek at night
yawning during your therapy that's not
good
damn are you getting sleep
yeah no no i'm not how did you know it
was the right therapist
uh had you been with her before
no i i've been through a number of them
and they were all good but i was also
killed all the other ones no i just
i yeah you know i was in my what about
bob years where i just i i wasn't like
you know receptive to whatever was going
to happen or what i you know so uh yeah
i ended up taking some mushrooms that
kind of
i was like wow okay that's who i am
figured out who i was and that was right
when i started therapy again so then i
kind of had this really big breakthrough
thing and now i feel like it's kind of
starting to slow down again oh that's
interesting yeah
so it just means i gotta take more drugs
so it's the shrooms open what did you
learn in the shrooms
i i agree
i kind of yeah well you're cool i'm just
cutting it yeah yeah you're from the
farmland from the farmlands but we don't
have time to say
[Laughter]
um
i i just i had a bad trip
but it was a good trip because i kind of
saw all of this stuff that everything
was sitting on
and at first i thought it was my current
life i was like oh this goes all the way
back to childhood i got to figure out
what this is i need to be sober because
i'd already quit drinking then i kind of
replaced that with gummies and weed and
[ __ ] yeah and then i was like so
i mean i took that that little trip
there and i didn't even smoke a cigar it
was in february i didn't smoke a cigar
until like may
and i just went like
i was like
i just figured out who the [ __ ] i was
for the first time i was 52 almost 53.
so and when you say you figured out who
you were why i do stand up why every
good thing i did every bad thing i did
every person that i heard
what is that
what is it what is it yeah i want to
well
all right i do stand up because it's
literally the [ __ ] six-year-old me
going if i go i'm gonna go into this
room with all of these strangers i'm
gonna make them laugh they're gonna like
me and then no one's gonna hurt me that
is literally
all the way down to the to the brass
tacks of who the [ __ ] i am it's i do
this [ __ ]
so you will like me and you won't hurt
me yeah i mean so then there's the i
made that i made the mistake of thinking
that i was going to be get great as a
comedian and then everything else in my
life was going to fall into place and
what ended up happening is my my mid 30s
i i progressed as a comedian and
everything else was at the starting line
i mean i was sleeping on a futon i
wasn't in a relationship no kids i had
you know i had nothing going on but i
had this one thing that i knew how to do
because this was the only thing that i i
worked on but i also you know i
understood why i drank the way i did why
i couldn't just have a drink
you know why i had to [ __ ] rage why i
have like this
this lunacy in me so let me ask you this
nature versus nurture are you a result
of your
upbringing your family or is it just
kind of who you are
uh mainly my upbringing and then i would
say also it's a combination of both
65 35
oh no dude i would say
yeah i don't want to get it
you don't want to get it i mean
it's a high number dude it's a [ __ ]
high number because i'm kind of now like
like now looking back
on all of it and it's like the sort of
the end of the usual suspects where the
leg straightens out oh like oh what the
[ __ ] like
that was the coffee cup yeah i was being
fed up like i believed it was this
and now i realize it was that and it was
[ __ ] mind-blowing mind-blowing i
actually wrecked my car i sideswiped a
[ __ ] mail truck where you were you
were when you were on mushrooms no oh
just
the clarity
of oh
oh i mean i'm not going to get into this
[ __ ] you know but like
and then know the guy was parked on the
side of the road i was driving like two
miles an hour and they got those big
[ __ ] honey of a ham bumpers that
stick out yeah dude it caught my front
quarter panel and just like
[Music]
down this side cost me like [ __ ]
seven grand it was just everything two
new doors the whole [ __ ] thing
whatever i don't get into that but i
know who i am
and isn't it
what talk about an incredible luxury i
mean obviously there's the fulfillment
of stand-up but like
i believe independent of the work you've
done that
stand up
the conversation you have with the
audience it holds up a mirror like the
you know you think that like
what we say to an audience they're not
they're laughing they're contributing by
not laughing or laughing or booing or
clapping
but there's a lot of communication going
on and i think comedians learn a lot
about themselves from how an audience
reacts whether it's in a small club or
even in a big one you say something and
it comes across right but it also has to
be like how aware or open you are
receptive you are but even then you're
kind of like
you're skimming the surface so like uh
at least i was i'm probably
superimposing
who i was
before all this this [ __ ] uh
recent
things that i did so um
you know my whole thing was just trying
to make people laugh have a good set and
then get to the next level of the
business
it was really just sort of like
then i do this and then i get at
caroline's and i'm in new york and yeah
you do this and then go out to la and
get an agent
but it was just all like uh yeah it was
another thing i kind of learned that
achieving isn't living
like living is living yeah no i remember
i uh
finally got letterman
and uh
like i
you know it was great and
it had been a goal of mine
from the beginning and i was but like
there was part of me like
oh well
what do i do now like i
like i didn't like that's all i wanted
was to do a set on letterman you know
sure it was good because when people
were like people used to ask if you were
a comedian have you been on
letterman or tonight show and so but
it is weird because
you don't
really think beyond these or i didn't
think beyond these immediate goals
which are kind of
false it's like even it goes back to
like
the mentality of when you're in high
school and you're like you know what i'm
gonna i'm captain of the football team
there you go did it yeah like you don't
realize that that would be pretty
awesome you don't realize that
it's
once you're out of high school it's
irrelevant do i mean it's like i played
sports all my life and then i you know
but i mostly get cast as like victims
you know i know but don't you but
there's there's a thing though i think
with like sports though is if you play
organized sports there is something that
you learn in there that really isn't
talked about now because everything's
just considered like so much of sports
now is considered like male toxicity
like how you learn
how you know you learn your role where
you fit in
how to bring people up not be a negative
force you learn to how to lose how to
come back
from losing um
you learn how to lead how to learn you
learn all of this amazing stuff and so i
think being captain of the football team
means you had some sort of leadership
qualities i mean watch these [ __ ]
hollywood movies and it's just me oh
he's the best looking guy and he's a
douche and he treats the cheerleader
he's dating like [ __ ] i mean that's all
written from nerds yeah who didn't play
yeah for the most part i think um or you
know never talk to the cheerleaders i
mean they resent them so they just kind
of create this like when we were growing
up like they used to write shows about
guys guys and then somewhere along the
line it just became this making fun of
guys guys which needed to be done
because it really got ridiculous with a
lot of those action movies and [ __ ] but
like then it just kind of went to such a
level
that it's like wait but the guy's guy
does exist
yeah there is that guy who is just
confident and better looking than you
and tougher than you and is going to get
a better looking girlfriend than you and
you have to [ __ ] accept that it's he
doesn't always have an underlying
because he's a good athlete doesn't mean
he's not smart yes do you mean like
that's
but some of that's john hughes like if
that when they attacked john hughes
cliches of like
um you know the sexism they didn't
address all these other things but
um yeah no i think let me tell you the
story so i brought my title i love john
hughes yeah i i brought my 10 year old
to a knicks game which was amazing i'd
gone with my nine-year-old and um
and we were we had great seats and
um at one point and by the way this is
you know ten-year-olds they're not great
sports you know like when you play them
like i'll play him in soccer and
basketball and if he's winning by just
one point he just starts giving me [ __ ]
but we're at this
basketball game and
he was like he was like there's a lot of
poor sports here and i'm like what do
you mean he goes a lot of these people
are just like you know because people
are rooting for their team and kind of
like giving [ __ ] and i was like wow i
didn't even realize that so like along
with that leadership but then again
that's not my that's not my
mo like defensive knicks fans they
haven't won since 73 so but even you're
gonna hear some heckles i remember i did
a commercial for um this bank that had
nomar and derek jeter
and
we shot in between a double header and
then after we shot we went and watched
this the second game and uh
we were in a box seat and there was a
guy in the you know like up in one of
those
fancy uh lounges yelling obscenities
to the yankees this is back before
boston had won right you know
and he was standing next to a kid who
was saying the same thing you know [ __ ]
you yankees suck you know right and it
was just so it's like they can't hear
you
like there's they also like
they block it out like i actually think
like an nba player
if everyone was when they went to take a
foul shot yeah like part of a foul shot
is everybody screaming yelling and a
mascot moonwalking along the baseline i
think if everyone was just actually
quiet and you would throw them yeah that
would wrap because i think after a while
every time you take a foul shot there's
a bunch of people with those stupid yeah
those things they just turn into a blur
i know and also you know those things
too they're made out of plastic and
evidently all plastic [ __ ] lasts for
like 800 to a thousand years yeah so
just to try to rattle this guy for game
47 of the nba season those stupid things
are gonna float in the ocean for a
[ __ ] thousand years
oh that was depressing sorry nature and
nurture so you're
i i believe like
you i think nature or nurture works
i think you can get a better eye sense
of that
if you have some sort of a more like
less volatile
childhood or time that you grew up in
because i mean i don't resent you know
the [ __ ] that happened when i was
growing up it was a [ __ ] crazy time
it was crazy it was a crazy time you
know we were coming out of the 60s all
of these people had gotten whacked
i mean basically i think the statement
of the 60s was do what we say or it
doesn't matter black white male female
you're going to get you know a
convenient lone gunman is going to take
you out
uh vietnam war ended the gas shortage
and all of that the [ __ ] rust bet
everything was falling apart carter was
a very interesting thing i mean yeah
he's the only human being he's the only
human being i feel like that's been
president since and and i think the
proof's in the pudding all these other
[ __ ] [ __ ] what do they do they go
off they do the speech tour and they buy
a mansion on martha's vineyard this guy
won a pulitzer prize because
after after he was president he's still
building homes for the homeless in the
90s this guy is truly a public servant
those other guys they're eating [ __ ]
you know lobster and steak every [ __ ]
night i know because i've been on the
internet yeah well i also i mean look
i'd eat the lobster and steak too
i can't eat lobster you can't i just
don't like the why can't they kill them
right before they put them in the pot do
they have to boil them alive well i
think it's illegal to boil them alive
now in some states in some states
to boil them alive is illegal
it's illegal to do it they have to kill
him first and i guarantee you that will
be politicized
i'm sure well i don't know what state it
is
kill your lobster first did you vote for
hillary clinton during the room
you're a trumpster well the we were sent
uh some lobsters from
made lobster something company
and i did it with my two youngest and
and they didn't you know put them in
there and you hear them scream
and and my my youngest was like like
pissed at me for like a week
because you do hear like
yeah they say that they should say
that's the air air coming out of the
shell and it's like no it isn't no it's
not
oh god why [ __ ] humans are the worst
we are the [ __ ] worst well as long as
we don't but it's like
you know i love a steak but you know i
never look yeah but they [ __ ] kill
the thing
yeah they don't throw the cow or the
steer on the [ __ ]
in the background all right it's simply
safe everybody
you know
if you ever wanted to make your home
feel safer
i need a safe space you guys there's no
better time than now sorry i just woke
up sorry about the sound of my voice all
right you do five [ __ ] shows in
indianapolis
um
this week my friends at simply safe are
giving my listeners early access to all
their holiday deals forty percent off
their award-winning home security i love
simply safe because it has everything
you need to make your home safe indoor
and outdoor cameras comprehensive
sensors no feminists all monitored
around the clock by trained
professionals who set up who helped set
it up the instant you needed simply safe
was even named the best home security
system of 2021 by u.s news and
world report
you can easily customize a system at
your house online in minutes and even
get free custom recommendations from
simply safe these are simply safe's
biggest discounts of the year
you can get a complete home security
system starting at just over a hundred
dollars
100 big ones
um 100 bucks sorry uh there are no
long-term contracts or commitments it's
really easy it's a really easy way to
start feeling a bit more peace of mind
take advantage of simply safe holiday
deals and get 40 percent off your new
home security system by visiting simply
safe dot com slash bur again that's
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot-com
for 40 off your entire system
all right lastly but not leastly it's
solo stove
dude
there's nothing quite like the feeling
of gathering around a warm fire on a
cool evening and a smokeless fire pit
from solo stoves makes your outdoor
moments even more memorable
because instead of having to constantly
dodge campfire fumes you can sit back
relax and then actually enjoy the fire i
want to give this to a homeless
encampment
now then they probably fight each other
over and with solo stove's holiday sale
you can get a great deal on a solo stove
fire pit solo stove fire pits are
brilliant brilliantly engineered
made with premium grade 304 stainless
steel
whatever the hell that is sounds
impressive
it almost went around the whole way and
a 360 degree airflow system that
maximizes efficiency while minimizing
the smoke that's the best right there
no smoke in your face easy to light with
a few bits of starter your fire is
blazing in minutes perfectly portable
take solo stove with you on camping
trips and more let the grit the gifting
begin
solos shop solo stoves holiday sale for
huge site-wide savings now through the
end of the year and get ten dollars off
with the promo code burr plus a lifetime
warranty and a free
free 30-day returns get an extra 10 off
holiday deals at solostove.com
promo code burr s-o-l-o-s-t-o
dot com promo code burr but having said
that
you know like nature is so [ __ ]
brutal like there was these two straight
kittens that were coming into our yard
and i couldn't coax them in they
wouldn't trust so we leave out food and
it took me three days and i'm starting
to gain that trust and the sun went down
i heard a horrific noise and i haven't
heard seen him since
and so that's probably like a coyote a
coyote probably killed him or a raccoon
or another [ __ ] cat and they don't
give a [ __ ] how cute those things are
all they see is vulnerability and it's
just like and it's just been it's been
[ __ ] me up the whole week going what
could i have done to got the goddamn
things in the house my wife's allergic
to [ __ ] cats i was trying to get them
to go downstairs i mean i got little
kids they're not the clawed i don't know
what's gonna happen i i have no [ __ ]
idea and then i'm thinking who are the
[ __ ] people that just let these
things go i'm hoping maybe somebody in
the neighborhood got him and then they
just put a noisemaker there to make it
sound like they were killed well dude i
hear noise outside my house all the time
i heard one night i think it was a
coyote and a raccoon going at it and
dude it was like it was [ __ ] it was
like that the first ufc before was the
ufc when you could punch in the balls
and gouge eyes and stuff that's what it
sounded like was going on outside
just blood curdling and don't you do you
have do you still have your dog
no my my dog i gave away my dog right
before my daughter was born because it
was just aggressive and she ended up
meeting my daughter and growled at my
daughter so i was just like yeah so my
dog uh
my owner my owner my trainer
took it i was still the owner uh it was
a weird sort of setup there i was still
the owner but he had it for like the
last uh
almost five years since she just passed
away of uh congestive heart failure wow
uh but you know i used to say that good
run she had a great wrench 13 years a
pit bull that's aggressive towards
people that usually get put down within
the first year a year and a half i would
think this thing lasted for 13 years and
um he's you know my trainer you know
would send me all this great video lived
out in arizona show me all this great
video her rolling around the grass
having a great time and when he would
come out to l.a he'd always bring her
and i'd see her so every month or two i
get to take her on a hike
and um you know but i i cried when we
gave her away but like by then it was
like five years had gone by and also
when she growled at my daughter
i knew
i was like okay i made the uh yeah yeah
right that's right decision yeah i still
love that [ __ ] dog man yeah
it's crazy they're just they don't
complain they don't do anything they're
just there
they're ready to go you know pit bulls
are awesome i mean we had a crazy one i
mean it was literally like uh
you know my trainer said you know this
is one of these dogs nature said no to
but some person said yes to
because the thing was [ __ ] nuts
it was nuts but i'm not down on the
breed whatsoever because i i love those
dogs i love pickles yeah uh but i you
know it's like anything you know you get
a lemon every once in a while yeah
my whole
i feel like my body's a lemon
um do you do anything i i literally
right before i came here i went to the
heart doctor i've had it yeah yeah i've
had a couple of buddies of mine you know
diet heart attacks one guy was a little
bigger another guy would just look like
me
and just
had look at the widow maker i think yeah
or something like that i don't know what
so i've been going
every year you know old dad i got to get
my ticker checked out so i i do that and
uh
you know i try to keep my weight down
and that type of [ __ ] i don't know well
you know like the let's talk about the
weight down like
they're like i tour i don't care i'll
i'll tell the name todd glass i i tour
with thai glass i love tagline todd's
one of the funniest cars he [ __ ]
heats i tour with him we go out to
dinner after the show he'll eat twice as
much as me
twice as much as me everybody works out
no i work out too i work out
you don't believe me at all
i work out some i i worked all right
look at like walking to the microphone
no
oh my god this is when you know you
don't work out when you take pictures of
yourself no this is an instagram
i'm not taking pictures i'm showing you
that this all right that's
all right look at this
look at this hold on oh wait he has some
sort of app out here look at this that
is graphing something okay
these are look at these what are those
these are my fitness rings how many are
closed all of them
what has closed me close means that
what does it mean 76 minutes exercising
974. wait but what does this thing
actually watch you exercising you're
just walking around no this is me
exercising so look what are you doing
elliptical
yoga
i mean
look yeah but what how does this thing
know if you just said i just did a half
hour yoga time it measures your heart
rate how does it know it measures your
heart rate
you don't believe me at all
i don't think that you just [ __ ]
worked out
200 days in a row no i don't i did i did
i don't look it right you just [ __ ]
said i did twice and both times you
averted your eyes you go like i did i
did i did i worked out well i can tell
you dropped weight i'm not trying to
bring no no i'm not trying to bring it
down or nothing like no but i'm just
saying that like their [ __ ] act is
about how you just like eating cookies
yeah i know but like no but like half of
why did i just tell you what your acts
about oh is that what it's about bill
sorry i'm on i don't know but like the
uh but my point is and i'm not saying i
have a condition where i gain weight i'm
not talking i have big bones i'm not
saying that but i am saying that some
people you got that farmer built no but
yeah that's the thing is that some
people
like like was your dad fat was your mom
fat no
genetically you're thin are you asking
me that yes oh yeah no you don't even
know what you're talking about i don't i
have to i have to [ __ ] eat
borderline i'm 53 i get borderline
perfectly and work out and i still gain
like five [ __ ] i go to the gym ten
days in a row have one douche of a day
and i'll gain like three [ __ ] pounds
it's brutal yeah so yeah so i work on it
so don't [ __ ] you you [ __ ] all you
baby guys angry about you [ __ ] big
bone guys
um i'm not angry about it no i'm not
really angry about this it's about that
[ __ ] from before so i'm already idling
at an eight it is listen yeah all of you
guys do that [ __ ] what's that you guys
who are out of shape see someone who's
in better shape and go oh dude yeah you
can [ __ ]
women do that i understand
women say guys just think about losing
weight and they lose weight that's
actually like a catchphrase among women
i understand that but what i'm saying is
that i here i'm going to pull it up i'm
going to pull it up here dude [ __ ] those
nerd nerds all these things like oh look
my watch said i took 10 minutes i said i
did my watch said i did
look at this look at those sneakers you
don't work out what what [ __ ] look at
this i i got these for my special i
didn't buy these geez like by the way i
don't buy clothes i still got this
[ __ ] thing going on no but all right
let me ask you this
your your mom and dad thin or not
uh
no my dad's not then no your dad was all
right so when you worked in his office
thin or not so when he was in his 50s no
no he was one of those guys who was thin
and then then metabolism catches up
catches up and then he wasn't then
i just but this whole idea that you're
just oh you're just real thin in your
50s and you can [ __ ] eat moon pies
it's it's not true there's there's some
people like i have a friend who i went
to college with
who's like this big
she's i mean she's asian but like she
eats like [ __ ] boatloads
you don't buy it
simple math dude you gotta eat you can
see but wait a minute you consume more
calories than you i'm not saying some
people's idol is higher but this idea
that there's people out there that well
into their 50s and 60s can be eaten five
six thousand calories and still eat like
they're a sophomore in college and
aren't fast i don't disagree with that
at all but are you saying i don't know
what you're saying are you saying that
like rob lowe
doesn't have a genetic advantage
now what are we talking about i'm
talking about like women he's comparing
he's like 80 years old
and he looks like he's 30. when we were
little kids rob lowe was like 40. robin
i was a god
no but that's my point my point is
right it's not you know something i
think and god cried with him yeah well
he slapped us together he actually tried
with rob
that's what i'm saying takes care of rob
lowe
like like a classic car
do you think rob lowe is like sleeping
in
uh oxygen tanks every night no he hasn't
he works his ass off
i don't know i i think he does i think
you're a hater
no i'm not a hater you're a child i'm
a gym hater jim hater don't know
jim gaffigan jim hayden i'm not well
look
the point is is like
also there's a difference between like
uh
i bet he has all of his meals like like
he knows what he's going to eat and they
come in those little glass
uh tupperware things and he sits and
somebody brings them and then he eats
you know like it's like but here's the
thing that's what i would think so do
you
like look there's a difference between
like like tom brady like you know
there's a rumor that he he doesn't eat
bread or he hasn't eaten bread in like a
decade or whatever
and it's like the whole cheat meal thing
like
there is the difference between like so
do you most people when they do a cheat
meal they do the whole day
they they go oh this is my cheat day
it's not a cheat day it's a cheat meal
and so do you do that do you have a
trainer
no
it's harder to eat healthy when you have
little kids right and that they're
having uh their meal and you're like
sitting there going here finish your
yeah and then you don't want to throw
out the food yeah i have that like my
kids they like pancakes and waffles they
would eat that literally every single
day they get excited they're rocking
back and forth and i'm literally doing
the cosby bit dad is great yeah
chocolate cake and i just do it and then
when they don't finish something do you
like this you know i'm like i'm not
throwing this out so then you know but
um but there's times when you have more
discipline than others
yeah right right now i'm in a
disciplined time
because i i've just i've had it with
myself so i gotta i gotta drop these
these you know i put on like 20 during
covert so i'm trying to take off i'm i
got like another 10 i got to take off
and do you run
no god no
why would you do that
i mean i would i don't know i would run
if someone was chasing me but i'm not
going to wear out my knees before the
axe murderer gets there
i don't understand my knees don't even
work anymore by the way but i think some
of that is
look i talked to rogan during the
pandemic uh because i
no i talked to him and i said i texted
with him i'm like look i want to lose
weight and he said cut out sugar cut out
bread
and i did lose weight
and so and by the way
you cut out sugar you cut out bread it's
like your joints hurt less
but after a while you're like
what am i living for
do you know what i mean
you're family you know yeah but yeah
i mean
i gotta be honest with you when i cut
out sugar yeah when i look at desserts
it doesn't even look like it's edible it
looks like clown food like something
like clowns would eat and they'd never
have to put makeup on like just with all
of the wild colors
the creams and all of that [ __ ] it just
looks it looks stupid to me um and by
the way i think it's you know this is
totally a cop out and an excuse but
i feel like when you're traveling when
you're touring
i find it harder to eat healthy too
because it's like
if you're going out to eat first of all
we know every restaurant you know a key
ingredient is butter and everything
but
so you can eat healthy don't you find it
depressing you're like oh you know what
uh after my show i'm gonna go and have
this tupperware in my hotel room like
how do you unwant you have a cigar and
you
have a meal right
um
no i i find the frustrating thing about
touring is that
you always have to be on like the first
flight out because it's like this is a
show day what if something happens it's
like they have forecasts
yeah and if it's [ __ ] clear i can
leave it and it just doesn't happen you
gotta [ __ ] get up at the [ __ ]
crack of dawn
and then what happens is then you run
down you just did a show you were wired
from the show you couldn't go to sleep
and then you got to wake up at six in
the morning to get to the [ __ ]
airport and then what i've learned is
when i land i'm gonna work out if i do
that i'm already so run down breathing
all this [ __ ] in i'm gonna go down to
the gym hotel gym and i'm gonna get sick
so then what happens is i don't do it
and then i'm missing my kids and i'm
frustrated that's usually when i'll
order the burger yeah so um but i mean
yeah so i think we're agreeing on a lot
of stuff but i'm not agreeing with like
this whole you know
this this whole thing i know this guy
there's this guy no yeah all right the
guy eats
[ __ ] bison
and he doesn't
i'm not
under the bus i mean he's a beloved
comedian he's beloved by everyone he's i
love him and but like what i would say
is that
look there there are different bodies
your body type you could get absolutely
[ __ ] jacked
[ __ ] yolked look at you dude you got
those farmers you were throwing bales of
hay at three years of age out there in
indiana dude you could get no you look
like you know what you look like you
look one of those [ __ ] guys on the
strong man things you see on espn yeah
those guys are all from like pharaoh
islands cons or whatever yeah no i uh
no i i'm just saying that there is
you know we were talking about the hard
thing your knees all taped up with those
big pasty thighs picking up those
[ __ ]
rocks you see all those big round balls
that they set down
wheeler i love it you're one of the
strongest guys in the world and now
we're gonna destroy your body
pull this tree it's like what's so
fascinating is they're all from the
faroe islands they're from iceland and
the faroe islands it's like nothing to
do with these places so they lift
weights but
my point is that there are
differences you know there are
differences i'm not saying that like
people that eat unhealthy aren't going
to gain weight i'm not saying that like
if i
if i ate like i ate when during the
lockdown i would be
much thinner you know what i mean but
i'm just saying that like
you know there are people that have
different metabolisms i'm not saying
that i don't eat unhealthy all right
that's right but if you just said that
in the beginning yeah rather than
throwing the great todd glass under the
i'm not saying i don't know this guy can
find
anything he can
it's it's he can't
believe me he can not without working
out you just you have to and not at his
age you can't
it's i'm telling you i i bet you can't
handle todd glass's workout
i bet you couldn't handle it that's
obviously not true
like i mean you know like yeah i can
totally handle his workout you're
talking about ty glass's workout like
it's like like it's like he's a ufc
fighter you can't handle the toddler
he's eating but i'm going off of your
information he's eating the way you're
saying he's eating well this guy [ __ ]
he goes to steak and shake he [ __ ]
he'd say if he's doing that and he's in
the shape he's in that [ __ ] guy works
out like an animal at his age
i well i know for a fact he does the
elliptical and it's you know
what
what's wrong with the elliptical
there it is what he works out
yeah okay and he also i bet doesn't eat
anything maybe he's on the road he says
[ __ ] it i'll eat like an animal but i
bet when he eats clean when he's in la
you with your myths
it's all about superstition
you know that's i have this theory that
most comedians i was thinking you know
when i [ __ ] up in high school i never
said to smart kids just like dude you
don't even have to study i mean you just
look at a book and you know everything
in it like that's what out of shape
people do to in-shape people oh yeah
yeah no that's
i remember they don't want to hear that
you actually have to work well by the
way i say that to my kids you're
terrible people you know like uh
like all those kids at school that say
they don't study they're lying
you know right they're just as dumb as
you are son no that it because that is
the
it's just like you know you do it you go
into a
uh you know it's kind of like comedy
it's when you see someone do a show it
it gives the appearance that they're
just making it up but of course we know
that there's work that goes into that
right
do you know what i mean well there is
also catching a zone and going off there
are those things you know you tap into
the rage some people are born with it
but it's all about the work
what if i do this
you don't even have to you mean you just
walk on stage and people start laughing
i mean you don't have to work at it
that's a nonsense you just you have like
this high comedy metabolism high
carbohydrate mental symbolism the jokes
just they just hit the page
it all works they write themselves
so what um so is all things comedy
is this what is the um
i mean i i you know i love it you're
looking at me like i'm gonna [ __ ] on it
i'm not
no no i just i've never understood the
confusion about it was a podcast network
that now turned into a production
company ah
yeah
well i don't know it's pretty
straightforward we've seen the shows
it's been in the trades yeah and acting
like you know i'm not see you assuming i
i know you got you know nominated for a
[ __ ] cable ace award i knew that
cable ace award man remember those yeah
yeah it's crazy that was that was the
that was the basic cable emmy
because the emmys would not acknowledge
cable and now the i always like how they
do that like how like
you know those award shows
they act like whatever the new platform
is gets treated like the latest
immigrants to the country they just get
shunned
yeah you you're not real television this
is real television i love it when
there's shows that
are completely ignored
by uh shows movies everything
like the the they miss the whole thing
and then they're embraced as brilliant
like the wire like the wire never
cleaned up
at those uh awards things or like when
they they
just keep not giving somebody an award
and then in the end they give me their a
lifetime achievement award yeah yeah or
they give an award for a movie that
wasn't nearly as good as their previous
work
yeah yeah and it's just like
i mean that's one of those things why i
sit there and i watch people like [ __ ]
about not getting an award and you just
look at like i'm trying to think of
somebody like say mark martin scorsese
yeah how many [ __ ] movies did that
guy have to put out before they finally
gave it to him for the departed but he
doesn't win it for a raging bull he
doesn't win if a taxi driver he doesn't
win it for [ __ ] uh uh uh goodfellas
the casino
you know i i just
it's just
there's only one trophy
well i think it's funny that adults get
upset that they're not winning a trophy
there's just something so [ __ ]
hilarious about that like especially if
you were like nominated
there's just something funny and you're
going to go there all up and like
somebody else wants it
well it's also
intellectually you know that it's
you know comparing
whether it's different movies or
different shows is an absurd task like
you can't compare
this show to that show
and say which one was better
yeah you know like the you know like
that that's not it's like which one did
you like better so
if someone enjoys the sopranos
you don't need an award but you do see
like
i understand it for writers though i
learned that doing efforts for family as
always is if you get nominated and
nominated just nominated or won then
that can up your fee you know like i am
i don't understand emmy nominated emily
so then it's like i understood it but as
far as just like the individual
you know going up there being upset it's
just [ __ ] it's just there's something
hilarious about it you know i understand
like racially if they just cut out your
whole race i get those people but white
people i guess
basically being like this
you know but it is i can't believe that
they charged this over my they said dude
but you were there i tried to do a joke
about how cares
um
how like uh
like if you look at most award shows
they're good look they're all
good-looking people too they're all very
attractive they should be and here's no
but here's how good how here's how i'm a
big fan of good-looking people and then
but here's treated better but the the
good-looking people here's how
consistently good-looking people win
awards
when a normal-looking person wins an
award you kind of think wow they must be
really talented because there's such a
standard
for attractive people winning awards
it's like
best i never think that you never think
that no i i
usually probably saw what they're
nominated for if i'm sitting there
watching it
and i'll be like yeah oh maybe i thought
the other person should have won
or whatever but i got to be honest with
you i kind of miss good-looking people
what do you mean miss them uh you know
they're they're getting rid of them
what are you talking about they're
putting regular people on billboards
why don't you watch british television
shows there's no comparison they [ __ ]
talk too fast and i can't understand
what they're saying and i know i just
don't like like i i'll watch like uh
i watch the first couple episodes um
first see couple seasons of peaky
blinders and then my drinking went off
the rails because everybody was just
boozing on there and i was drinking a
lot and so i kind of was like i could
stop watching this [ __ ] i'll blame the
tv show yeah that's that was the reason
that was the number one because of close
alcoholism
uh me tv
you want to quit drinking and smoking
don't watch me tv what's me tv oh my god
what me tv what is that
it says [ __ ] it was it my entertainment
i don't know it's all the legendary
shows we grew up heroes and icons
channel oh i don't dude if you want to
watch like every episode of [ __ ] man
you're retired how do you know about all
these things well what am i gonna watch
some [ __ ] the some [ __ ] show about
a witch
whenever everything was about vampires
and dracula i just was like i'm too old
for now tv
and then it just all became like these
[ __ ] superhero movies how many
[ __ ] more can they do
and they all have the same [ __ ]
storyline
either something radioactive happened to
you or you got [ __ ] up as a kid or are
you from another planet
society doesn't understand you hell is
[ __ ]
oh my god it's the same [ __ ] story
over and over again over and [ __ ]
over again it is pretty amazing
the
and they have blown out every
like i swear to god like has robin
gotten his own movie yet that's like the
only guy left oh i'm sure let's do a
[ __ ] story on how he became the ward
of uh bruce wayne
that's what they should do and they
should make him gay like everybody
always thought was going on he already
is gay all right so they make him gay
and then you could at least [ __ ] do
that you bring harvey malkin you sean
penn plays brings back harvey milk
he saves harvey milk he saves harvey
miller like a tarantino thing change
history instead of manson family
succeeding they don't he saves harvey
milk
yeah i mean then he finally sets out
they get married he [ __ ] sets out he
gets away from [ __ ] batman that toxic
relationship right because he had anger
issues you know from when he was a kid
right
yeah you know i don't know that's a good
[ __ ] movie that's you you pitched it
you pitched it right here hey dude we
should write it what
what is
it it's the superhero like i remember
when i was a kid and star wars came out
and i was kind of like all right this is
this is uh you know i liked it but i
didn't you know like i had friends that
were like crazy i had friends that were
crazy about the rock band kids i was
like go at it go have fun yeah and and
then um
but now it's just
it's not even a generation it's
generation upon generation of like you
know i took my kids to star wars movies
every christmas for like five years
straight it's just
there's it's not just the superheroes it
is like
this uh
it's you know it's weird there's a great
book about how he's trying to make your
kid cry or scare the [ __ ] out of him
well they kill like main character how
old
my daughter's like crying i'm like it's
just a movie it's they killed han solo
dude i mean when we saw et when that
[ __ ] thing almost died yeah something
happened in that i remember one of my
siblings was [ __ ] bawling his eyes
out i remember we made fun of him of
course but that's how it was back then
but i just remember now that i have like
like i'm trying to think how old does my
daughter have to be where i could take
her to a rated g movie one of the
parents at my daughter's school
asked me he goes hey man i'm taking my
daughter you want to come with me and i
just couldn't make it i'm glad i didn't
he goes oh my god he goes they showed
some super sad cartoon before it was
somebody dying and his kid was just
balling and i'm like why do they [ __ ]
do that
or what they do is they'll come in there
and they know that
the movie's so young that there's a
bunch of parents there and then they'll
advertise the movie to try to get the
parents to go there and they'll scare
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of your kids
showing some like you know pg-13
rated r [ __ ] you know yeah maybe not
rated r no yeah they wouldn't do that
yeah i don't know i mean i just feel
like it all comes back to todd glass and
his metabolism it is it is ty glass's
metabolism i gotta text him and let him
know that i'm outing his uh metabolism
yeah todd he says you don't have to you
don't have to work at all he doesn't eat
whatever you want steak and shake night
after it's not steak and chicken it's a
steak
and then he has a shake it's different
than
the thing
what sort of steakhouse do you go that
actually has a shake there's only one
place that does that that's no chick
that's well i'm sure there's more than
one
it's not like the only place that has a
steak name another place where you can
get off you can get a chocolate malt
after a rib eye
um
look at you you missed a food guy
stumped you
this is like stumping the swami on the
uh [ __ ] espn back in the day
the swami swamy or you'd see
what's his face on that metal show
eddie trunk yeah there was any eddie
trunk of food
yeah
no i can't there's got to be something
but like i'm talking about like a
steakhouse steakhouse yeah steakhouse
steakhouse where they got all these
bourbons and then all somebody in the
corner is making a shake at the bucket
no i'm sure on dessert they have some
decadent thing you know you ever get no
this is what you're doing now you're
[ __ ] you're expanding what you just
said you just said this that's not the
only place that does it and i said it i
always whenever i talk to you i feel
like i'm talking to a lawyer it's just
like
lawful and i mean because then when it
makes it seem ridiculous that five
minutes ago i disagreed with you when
you smooth everything out you know i
don't know it takes me that back to
remember that one of my favorite paul
ryzer jokes
somebody's telling you a story and they
go hey you know correct me if i'm wrong
because correct me for wrong i wasn't
even there how about you come back when
you know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about that's funny
that's funny
it is funny it is funny comedy's funny
paul reiser i saw him tape a special in
new york when i
ran i think i i don't think i had even
tried stand up
and he came up during that time
when if you actually got a sitcom on the
air you weren't sad when he had and got
that the 100th episode that's what
everybody was going for and it was like
there was that weird thing where you
know
that is flipped where
you stopped doing comedy
because you were making so much money
doing tv
yeah and now it's like
you know you go you do a tv show no now
as a comedian it actually costs you
money
yeah it's crazy
what's crazy is it's just as much work
as it ever was to do a tv show it's just
that this is what happens when everyone
gets one i think
um
we were on a uh streaming service the
other night
i was was i was on uh i was watching the
new south park have you seen what they
got no no oh it's like posted the
christmas one it's the one where the
kids are all grown it's post coven and
what happened dude it's pretty dark man
it's pretty crazy so i was just kind of
going through all of those things and i
well this one streaming thing there was
just so many good shows
it was just overwhelming and what always
happens i just shut it off and then i
just go and i'll watch like jack lord on
hawaii 5-0
or i'll watch uh you know robert stack
the untouchables no there's a lot of
shows
jack in the fat man what about rockford
files did you ever watch that i loved
the rockford files right and i never
realized how [ __ ] up his personal life
was he lived in a mobile home mobile
home like down on the beach
i always thought it was a cool house
yeah no it was a mobile home he had a
cool car didn't he yeah he couldn't he
couldn't like no he didn't he actually
had a station wagon no he had he had the
the firebird
uh
a spirit i think it was so remember how
like the with the with the camaro there
was the z28
the berlinetta
the rally sport and then i think there
was a base model so like they all had
the same body type but they all had
different suspensions and engines so the
z28 was the one that you wanted so with
the firebird it was the trans am then
the formula 400 and then the espirit i
believe so
this is kind of interesting because this
is right before burt reynolds did um
smoking the bandit and made that car
iconic so when that thing was coming to
series they wanted to give them
uh the trans am with this the you know
whatever they call it the [ __ ]
flaming eagle on the uh
and he goes no man this guy wouldn't
drive that because he was going like
this guy lives in a trailer home yeah
yeah um
and then they go all right
what about if we give you the formula
400 which had the trans am i think the
6.6 liter in it it just didn't have all
the decals but it still had the side
scoops and the hood scoops so it still
looked badass so he said all right get
me the formula 400 and have it look like
in a spirit so that's why it had the
radial white wall tires wow and it had
those rims on it and stuff but actually
under the hood he had a badass engine
there were a lot of guys
you know like so there was
uh who was jack klugman living on a boat
he was an md
um you know it was later on
quincy there were a lot of these guys
that were just like these
like
lone rang like solo guys just kind of
you know they were having some fun but
like they lived kind of a simple life
that that probably had an impression on
us that's why we're in comedy and we're
in our i know but it's living by
ourselves because quincy and
and
that's also writers in the writers room
and i think they they would live
vicariously through them like what if i
didn't get married what if i was a
badass and that type of stuff so they
wrote all these [ __ ]
these great guys and i think they just
they created this standard of guy that
nobody could live up to and then i think
like the last 20 years has been about
sort of tearing that guy down
um
i don't know and maybe i don't know
maybe i don't like that they do that a
lot of shows do that now because it
makes me feel um makes me feel old
or stupid because i used to watch i
watched all of those action hero guys
saw every one of those movies so it's
funny i'm sitting here making fun of the
[ __ ] marvel movies and all of that
[ __ ] so what happened meanwhile what
actually every [ __ ] one that came out
every schwarzenegger okay every every
chuck norris every sylvester stallone
every muscle from brussels that guy
every [ __ ] steven seagal
uh i used to watch
ones of people that they you know like
guys who would get spit like guys would
uh
the guy played ivan drago i think he had
a couple where they tried to make him a
star in those things i watched all of
every by the way he's super smart by the
way
i think he's like a genius oh he is all
right
i never thought he was stupid
well you said he was stupid no but like
i said every stupid movie i went out
yeah oh no i was joking
i didn't mean it like that um but he
yeah those movies it's it's interesting
so like
there but like there was an ounce of
reality that existed in
the unbelievable
uh aspect of rambo do i mean but like
now they're just like they're like look
don't he doesn't even have to be a
vietnam vet he's just like a guy from
another planet but we i just watched the
last one i loved it it was just superman
right or and uh well right now i want to
i want to take back everything i said
about marvel
movies because now i realize that i was
the marvel movies i was watching them
growing up were all the action movies
which if you really looked at them so
many of them
were like you know a lot of the [ __ ]
that they still do today there's a guy
he used x military people come in they
[ __ ] with them don't realize they're
[ __ ] with the wrong guy it's the yeah
that what the [ __ ] that guy's name he
does all of those he does like nine of
those movies where it's just like if you
[ __ ] with my family oh yeah yeah liam
neeson i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
pick up the phone pick up the phone yeah
i'm gonna wrap it up around your [ __ ]
neck i don't wanna [ __ ] kill you but
like the the thing about the marvel
movies
is that and i'm because i have kids i
wouldn't have seen them but i have seen
them is they are
you know there's a lot of complex
storyline i love the batman one it's
still you know like a guy in tights but
i know they're better than you had
whatever i'm just a [ __ ] old guy
bitching i will tell you i did see
superman vs batman
and i should have brought earplugs i
mean i thought ac dc was quieter than
that [ __ ] movie it was so
[ __ ] loud and they just beat the [ __ ]
out of each other destroyed a whole city
and they literally
there was like 100 skyscrapers and they
threw each one another into like 98 of
them wow
and you know it's like did you ever see
the 300
the chrysler 300 no it's it's a movie
called the 300 i think it was called the
300. i think it was called 300 300
300 how old do we sound
what did you see the 300 there was
did you see the john elton concert
well you were a fan of the star wars did
you see the seinfeld
my dad used to say that is she on that
internet
that internet that internet
i don't know
what about 300 300 i liked
yeah see like it was interesting but i
it was
so kind of special effect-y i was kind
of
like when it comes to history i love
history so i was like more history less
less airbrushed abs
yeah or just kind of like now there's a
monster that comes out of the ground
that you have to deal with